bonjour remercier d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors expliquez nous comment
est-ce qu'on peut justement expliqué ce
blocage politique au liban l'ancien
premier ministre saad hariri a été
chargé de former un nouveau gouvernement
pourquoi c'est si compliqué qu'est ce
qui coince
ce qui compte c'est que nous sommes face
à une crise de système donc c'est un
système de pouvoir kirca parle de
opérationnellement de prendre des
décisions parce que chaque décision qui
serait dans l'intérêt général
reviendrait à mettre une est un plus qui
n'a entravé les réseaux de clientèle de
chacun des chefs communautaires donc en
fait la visite de monsieur le drian
revient à constater cet échec là après
que ce qu'on a appelé l'initiative
française a tenté une nouvelle fois de
donner une chance à ce système politique
libanais que nous considérons en crise
complète c'est-à-dire en août quand le
président m'a cours est venu proposer un
gouvernement de mission avec les mêmes
responsables politiques ils misaient
encore sur la possibilité pour ce
système de s'auto réformée aujourd'hui
cette visite est un constat d'échec le
le ministre français l'a dit lui-même il
y as non assistance à pays en danger et
donc il est en train de tourner la page
avec une approche en deux temps mais qui
n'est pas encore complètement clarifier
la première c'est de d'entamer des
sanctions envers ses responsables mais
ce n'est pas encore clair quelle sera
l'ampleur
quels seront l'ampleur de cette sanction
on parle de d'interdiction d'entrée de
territoire sur le territoire français
on ne sait pas par exemple si ça
concerne des binationaux parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de binationaux libano autre
inconnue ban est parmi les responsables
politiques qui ne part et de l'autre il
ya une main tendue à l'opposition
libanaise
les nouvelles formations ou d'anciennes
formations qui se déclarent désormais
dans l'opposition au système politique
libanais monsieur védrine les a
rencontrés et leur a consacré davantage
de temps aux coaches traditionnels et
aux impôts aux responsables de
l'établissement qu'il est obligé de
rencontrer par des considérations
protocolaire et donc il ya eu de longues
discussions avec sa nouvelle formation
alors on a parlé des sanctions à paris
qui a annoncé avoir pris des mesures
vous l'avez dit contre certains
responsables politiques libanais
interdits d'entrée sur le territoire
français vous pensez que la france a
suffisamment de moyens pour faire
pression c'est l'un des enjeux de la
diplomatie française aujourd'hui c'est
qu'elle elle est loin de maîtriser tous
les leviers au liban il y amène entendu
les etats-unis l'iran qui a une relation
très étroite avec le hezbollah qui
les principaux partis au liban il ya la
russie qu'à une nouvelle un nouvel
acteur dans ce côté ci de la
méditerranée
d'autres forces du golfe l'arabie
séoudite et c'est donc la france n'a pas
toutes les cartes au liban et merci le
jeu libanaise avec défauts principaux
qui système politique libanais et qu'il
ne parvient pas à avoir une ligne
politique propre face aux autres quels
qu'ils soient aux autres pays quel qu'il
soit il y à une interférence permanente
entre les intérêts et les volontés de
l'influencent de de l'extérieur sur les
sur l'intérieur libanais à travers
chacun son canal communautaire
donc c'est là l'une des principales
problématiques aujourd'hui que les
forces d'opposition chercher pourquoi
expliquez nous pourquoi est ce cas
autant d' influence d'intérêt qui émerge
au liban on sait que c'est un un tout
petit pays de quelques millions
d'habitants selon pourquoi est ce que il
ya autour d' influence justement c'est
historiquement liés à la construction
communautaire du liban le liban a été
créée il ya cent ans déjà en tant
qu'etat mais l'état n'a pas prévalu sur
les intérêts des communautés et surtout
de jeu des chefs communautaires ou des
coudes et de ceux qui se sont arrogé la
la représentativité de ces communautés
large et dans un jeu de rapports de
force internes
ces chefs communautaires la rue
intérêt à s'allier avec puissance
extrême extrants gère pour par rapport à
l'or aux partis aux autres parties
libanaises
c'est ce jeu d'influencé extérieure
intérieure qui depuis des années
prévaut au liban puisque des années à la
décennie qui a conduit à la guerre du
liban notamment et kia qui a aussi
depuis la fin de la guerre du liban
faciliter les rapports de force internes
en suivant les périodes suivant que
l'ordre régional
il ya de la stabilité au liban le liban
et est voué à avoir une instabilité
politique ou est ce qu'il ya une
solution est ce que il faudrait
peut-être organiser de nouvelles
élections présidentielle législatives ou
est-ce que selon vous ça servirait à pas
grand chose
la stabilité des fonds de la
construction d'un état et pour
construire un état
il faut revoir les piliers de ce système
libanais ils sont nous en voyons trop il
ya à voir les principes mêmes de la
citoyenneté libanaise parce
qu'aujourd'hui elle et il n'y a pas de
principes unifiée de citoyenneté
libanaise sans que l'on soit shit
maronite orthodoxe bruges ou ou sunnites
le rapport à l'état est différent d'une
part il y à revoir le système politique
lui même parce qu'il ne fonctionne pas
et enfin il y avoir le pacte économique
et social
et c'est aujourd'hui la société
libanaise était en plein effondrement et
il n'y a aucun filet de sécurité il ya
redéfinir tout ça les forces
d'opposition sont en train de te dis
travailler et et de tracer aussi le
la trajectoire de la transition vers un
nouveau système est ce que ce sera des
élections ou plutôt c'est notre souhait
prioritaire un gouvernement de
transition
parce qu'il faut bien qu'on perd ne
manquez organiser de nouvelles élections
est ce que ce sera le système actuel qui
est en mesure d'organiser des élections
qui faciliteront une transition la
question reste bel et bien ce sera le
mot de la fin
sybille risque merci d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
directrice des politiques publiques de
l'eau angie kuluna irada merci beaucoup